[Music]
foreign
hey everybody it's Monday and that means
we're talking about ghosts and [__] yeah
we're gonna talk about
um Haunting in Florida again
yeah we I looked up when we talked about
that before it was way back on episode
44. so it was like more than five years
ago yeah it was a long time ago yeah and
this was a good episode and like I said
you know Tom knows the guy I know Ed
yeah so he's on my friends list right I
met him just met him by chance
it was down in um
went to the Ace Hardware store in
Sanford he's not working there now but
at that time he was working there yeah
it was a few years ago yeah went down
there to go get some machine grade bolts
for working on a Buell
and the guys
going through the machine bolts with me
and he's you know talking about you know
what grade I needed and this and that
you know I'm telling him he's looking
for it
and just voice sounded real familiar and
I looked at his name plate and said Ed
and I looked at his face in the bed it
was Ed Dunham from
I said man you're at Dunham from the
holiday and he goes yeah yeah and he
goes man it's nice to meet you
he goes you're not you're actually your
ex Ranger do you think yeah and you know
I told him so I'm x Hunter first
it's going to Recon platoon there it was
up at the 506 in Korea too when they was
back in the 506 was attached to the
second ID
it's when it's back at the 101st now
anyway uh he's like oh yeah yeah and it
says I saw some paranormal [__] too
because you did
and uh I told him just briefly about
Poltergeist Mountain that Jenny wrote
the book about when I told her the story
he's like yeah man [__] it was weird
man basically he told me the same thing
I'd say say to you that was a bad house
so he said
and um I got his got his contact on
Facebook
as back when Facebook was popular now
now that's old people
but uh
so ended up contacting him later and
finding more about the case and I was
talking to him on the phone yeah
yeah and I talked to him for several
hours
and then ran into him a couple other
times after that ran into him in traffic
I was riding a bike and he was driving
his [__] truck and like what's up man
hey you know if I could [__] like that
you know
I was talking to him he said he could
get on HRT and [__] so we talked mostly
online
yeah he kind of lived in the same area
yes like he lived in Sanford yeah yeah
and then uh he's not with the wife
that's in this episode anymore they
broke up yeah but uh his kids are all
grown now
and uh he ended up becoming a Justice of
the Peace and he would marry you all
right at the uh
and I guess his stick was is he'd uh
dress up in a dam Ranger outfit a U.S
Army Ranger outfit or he dressed up in a
kilt and uh marry you and they'd
probably yell at you to you he was
yelling if you're into that yeah yeah
because some people like that I guess
like yeah yeah get a ranger marriage
mr88 said how can I get your mailing
address just send me a message on
Facebook or Instagram I mean Facebook
probably is the most the quickest way
but or Instagram works too and um and
I'll give it to you because I don't
really like to just give it out on live
live you know what I mean
um I mean I don't know why because I
trust you [__] but like not to show
up on the doorstep or anything but well
it's better if you're one person
one-on-one you know who it is yeah
exactly
but uh so this is a case where I have
some um inside in because I I talked to
Ed personally I know him all right
all right um
he said he didn't want to be on a show
anymore I asked him years ago when we
first talked about his case asked him if
he wanted to uh come on as a guest and
he says no I don't want to talk about
that anymore so he said
I mean it was a long time ago like the
um the Paranormal Activity that he
experienced was back in 2001 yeah and
then I think the show came out in 2006
or 2007 and then we did a show about it
in 2017 and I think that I don't
remember when it was that you ran into
him but it was probably oh that was
about 2016 probably 15. something like
that but he said uh he said he's gonna
leave ghosts alone he says if he leaves
the ghost alone they'll leave him alone
yeah because they kind of went into that
a little bit on this show that he was
just getting very shouty with the ghosts
and the all the Paranormal people were
telling to knock that off because it was
just making it worse yeah
because he was getting really frustrated
he's a bad boy he's from you know bad
boys what we called a guy from the
ranger battalion I don't think he's not
tabbed he was just enlisted and um under
the command of the ragers and and you
know they're part of the bat and uh
they're hard on them they're good though
they're they're good dudes and um he has
[__] Army Ranger
assault infantry [__] attitude he's
just he's me well he's not mean just
any threat he was he's going to respond
to with hostility and he's going to
attack everything's a counter-attack you
know so I can I've been in this
situation something similar to this when
I was a kid
I could imagine coming out of a range of
battalion
how you'd react to something paranormal
yeah you know well you know [__] went
into the bad house after 101st but
Ranger is even more intense
um but I had experience when I went
later on when I got out of the Army and
went into that bad house but
nothing ever really happened there but
he was actually seeing [__] happening in
this one
um
so yeah I could imagine him [__]
getting pissed trying to fight something
that's invisible that's what he's
talking about says you couldn't shoot it
you couldn't grab it you couldn't fight
it he's and it was he said it was a
threat to his family it was driving him
[__] crazy because he felt impotent
in the face of it he didn't like that
feeling like I totally understand it
so he just got more and more hostile and
they may have been feeding off of him or
just tripping well that's kind of what
the Paranormal yeah interested it's like
you need to quit doing that because yeah
but he saw it and he saw the dude she
was just a dude who was [__]
smoking a cigar and wet clothes
just he was drenched and he could smell
that cigar smoke
he saw him dude looked right at him
and then he it startled him and he took
his eyes off him for a second and then
when he looked back he was gone
yeah we'll get into it yeah and he kept
seeing something up on the roof he heard
him walking up on the roof and went out
there and looked and so he
I asked him he said what exactly do you
did you see he just said it was just a a
dark
Mass like a like a cloud like a shape
says it wasn't even really human-like it
was just
a shake like a cloud
he said he couldn't really see it
because it was on a black background and
it was dark outside
but he could saw moving amorphous
shape
that's it that's all the only way he
could describe it
Mr 88 says uh I don't use Facebook or
Instagram do you have a website I can
send a message to you can go to the 13
o'clock podcast like website blog thing
um which I think is just what is it 13
o'clock podcast at wordpress.com or
something like that and I think there's
a thing on there where you can send a
message and that'll come to my email
so that works too but you know if you
just do a search for a 13 o'clock
podcast it should the website should
come up and there should be a message
thing on there because I have gotten
messages like through there before yeah
so I don't know exactly what Ed saw
I just know you saw something
as I'm gonna take him at his word he
said it was a ghost well his wife saw
some [__] too yeah like saw some
apparitions yeah
so and the sun did too didn't he I think
so yeah yeah we'll get into that
so uh so yeah this is actually one of
our favorite episodes like I said it
kind of became one of our favorite
episodes too after you know after Tom
ran into like Ed Dunham which is so
Random well it was one of my favorite
episodes before I yeah well and it's a
good episode too because it's like
um you know it's in Deltona which is
only like maybe like 20 miles from where
I grew up yeah and so I was like real
familiar with the area you know what I
mean so it was like kind of neat to see
one that was set somewhere like where I
knew where it was I also contacted um
Dusty the girl that ran the Paranormal
yeah a psychic that ran the paranormal
ghost hunting team and that's really all
it was and that was in Daytona and
that's that's where I'm from it was just
a local ghost hunting club in Daytona
really that's all it was yeah but I
talked to her briefly she I this is
before I was on this podcast and it was
before before uh the book came out I
need I don't think I even knew Jenny
when I was talking to them
I think I knew her but we weren't we
weren't an item
and uh so she I didn't really have a
reputation or a name so she really
didn't want to talk to me too much uh uh
it was on Facebook I was talking to her
like
um she didn't really want to get into
any details I wanted to ask her you know
where's the videotape
now
she seemed
just kind of basic like she knew she had
basic understanding of paranormal stuff
like you'd read it out of a book
um and she did have some experience
evidently a corridor
so I can't really say anything one way
or another I'm not a big uh
um
I'm not a big believer in having
psychics on board with a parrot with a
paranormal investigation I think they
muddy the water more yeah I don't think
it's a great I think it's a great idea I
think it's better to have a
parapsychologist or some kind of
investigator somebody who's neutral yeah
uh that's the best way to go
but you know she evidently helped that
out so I'll give her that
evidently we'll see though I don't know
because there's this
tape there's this claim of this tape and
a threat to the child
which I'm not sure was fully
substantiated because she didn't show
the [__] didn't show the [__]
videotape to you I mean they know yeah
and they never show like the real [__]
on haunting which is just their
I don't know I guess they just
established that as protocol because
they're like well in all and you know we
don't have evidence in all the cases so
let's just like not sure anything
so I I get it but it is kind of like
yeah you know
I don't know I'd probably let me see
that tape let me see that tape got there
well yeah you'd think that he would have
wanted to see it because I mean if [__]
went down the way it went down on the
show where like it was kind of a freak
out where it's like holy [__] I think
this like whatever it is is after your
baby yeah she evidently said no you
don't want to see it
that's really that's that's what that's
what I think that's far enough that's
what's coming to mind that she that it
wasn't wasn't good to show it but she he
didn't want to see it
I well I guess I understand that like I
said
but uh but yeah so that could have been
nothing to it well like that's another
thing it's not saying that there's none
to the case it just may have been
nothing to the videotape right right
all right so uh a haunting in Florida
this was from season two episode ten
like I said I think this came out
first air 2006 2007 something like that
and we first covered it back in 2017 but
we wanted to kind of revisit it because
this is a good episode
so yeah so the guy at the center of this
uh well his family anyway is Ed Too D's
Dunham
and his then wife Beth like I said
they're not together anymore uh but you
know obviously they were on the show now
at the time that this happened it was
like summer of 2001.
and they had
um a baby daughter named Emily she was
pretty little she looked like she was
like toddler age
now Ed also had a 12 year old son named
Matt from a previous marriage who just
comes and stays with them all weekends
so in June of 2001 uh the Dunhams are
looking for a bigger house you know
because they just had a baby and you
know I guess they're looking for more
room
now Ed as Tom mentioned uh was a retired
US Army Ranger and he now kind of works
he does like Contracting restoring
houses stuff like that he wasn't retired
they just called him to have the show so
he wasn't retired he was just discharged
and maybe maybe he he got an injury was
medically retired but he you know he was
too young to be retired
you know what I mean yeah I served 20
years
so you must he may have been medically
retired yeah naughty was just discharged
right like I got medical retirement you
know
it does happen yeah
Brian says hi Tom and Jenny long time no
speak well hi there what's going on
so apparently in his uh kind of new
career of restoring houses and whatnot
he had a friend who owned a bunch of
properties and news at the Dunhams were
looking for a house and he's like oh
I've got this really good deal like it's
in a you know decent neighborhood it's
on a nice Street and it's like
substantially like cheaper than the
other houses in the area
so they go there to look at it now
initially they said okay well the person
that owned it or who had been living
there left all the furniture and [__]
like that in there which they thought
was a little bit weird but not that
weird because I guess the guy said to
them it's like oh well the reason we're
giving you such a good deal on it is
because we want you to like pack up all
the other person's stuff and like get
rid of it so they're like okay whatever
but then when they actually got there it
wasn't just a case of oh they left their
furniture and their other [__] there
they like there was like half eaten food
like left in there like spoiled milk in
the refrigerator like it looked like
somebody just took off like like took
absolutely nothing with them yeah like
they ran in the middle of a meal right
and try to imply that yeah that's kind
of what they applied which like I said
it wouldn't be that weird if it was just
furniture and [__] like that because a
lot of people leave [__] behind if
they're just like oh [__] it I'm moving
across the country and I don't want to
like have to Lug all this [__] with me
I'll just buy a new [__] but yeah the
fact that there was just like half eaten
food left they thought that was very
strange yeah its wife is like what the
hell is all this he goes well I guess
when he met pack it up he meant pack
because he's getting paid to clean the
place up right and to pack certain
things up I guess he I guess that he
goes I guess that means cleaning this
place up and getting doing all this
dude's dishes too yeah
dirty dishes all over the place yeah I
would have just thrown them out and
started over to me yeah that's probably
what he did I'm sure yeah I mean because
like it's not you're not going to use
them or anything gross not gonna mix
them in with your dishes right that's
what I'm saying it's like you don't know
where the [__] that's been yeah he could
have like wiped his ass on that you
don't know I listen to gen
you don't know what people get up to you
[Laughter]
I know that's just no idea that's the
first thing my mind went to I don't know
I think wiped his ass
that's somebody's fetish somewhere
wiping their ass on the dishes and then
putting them back in them
[Laughter]
you know you've read some of my [__] you
read some of my fiction you know but uh
but yeah
so um they're like they got a really
really good deal on the house they said
you know it was kind of one of the
nicest ones in the neighborhood and it's
like it's not like a super super fancy
neighborhood or anything like that but
it was like a nice working to middle
class yeah I've been there it's nice
it's a little older neighborhood but
yeah yeah
and like you said the house that they
have on the show is not the actual house
but it's on the same street as the
actual house I think they mentioned
didn't they mention on the show that it
was Mason Street or may something like
that but I don't know if that's the real
name of the because I was I thought I
heard that that they said with the name
but I don't know if they gave the real
name of it but you found it I found it
so they were talking about it on Reddit
yeah I think it was Reddit or something
like Reddit uh paranormal a paranormal
uh
a paranormal thread somewhere talked
about that house in this episode and
somebody knew right where it was gave
the address and everything yeah because
obviously other people live around there
you would know where it was right and it
wasn't it's not the house that's shown
it says I think if I remember I think I
remember correctly the house that's
shown it even shows the uh the address
the numbers on the front of that house
and it's about six houses up from that
it's like a nice it's like a nice like
just a one-story like brick
I don't know what it looks like now
because it's been a long time but yeah
so Deltona if you don't know is
about halfway between Daytona Beach and
Orlando yeah it's maybe a half hour from
here huh yeah probably about that
probably about that
it's weird because I'm pretty sure on
the show they said oh it was like
um the biggest city in Volusia County
I'm like is it
I don't I find that hard to believe I
would have thought Daytona would have
been bigger but then I was thinking to
myself well maybe not because Daytona
Beach the Daytona Beach area is big but
Daytona Beach itself is comprised of a
bunch of littler towns you know it's
like you got Daytona Beach you got
Daytona Beach Shores you got Ormond
Beach you got Holly Hill you got Port
Orange you got
um you know so there's just like a bunch
of other
cities that are kind of all in the same
area that maybe aren't so I don't know
maybe that's what they consider that
it's all but I just I never thought of
Deltona as that big but I haven't been
there for a long time so I don't know
so yeah so they cleaned the place up and
they're like well you know it's we got a
really good deal on it so we're not
going to worry too much about all this
weird [__] that they left here
so they settle in and everything seems
fine like everything is just very quiet
and very comfortable and Beth was like
yeah it was really it's a really nice
place you know what I mean
in because
she in the they had kind of like a um
what do you call it like a not a sun
porch type of thing but you know the sun
porch thing and it's it looked like
glass
and they didn't have any blinds or
anything on it
um so she was kind of out there messing
around and she just kept thinking that
someone was watching her like from
outside yeah
um feelings of being watched yes that
was like the first
Camp guy said Deltona is a Great
Southern redneck name for a town it is
isn't it I always thought it was very
redneck come on down here Deltona
Deltona
got all kinds of got all kinds of food
grits they do hush puppies
hog Jaws
turned greens pickled pig's feet yeah
and it's still in the jar yep still in
the jar that's pretty much I haven't
been a Delta pickled eggs those fancy
pickled eggs
but Daytona's still pretty red now yeah
so I'm assuming that Deltona is even
more rednecky that's good it's built up
now though it is but there's still a lot
of red neckiness because Daytona is
built up a lot too but it's still like
kind of rednecky it got they started
building a lot of uh new uh enclosed
communities a real nice high-end houses
because people are moving here I mean
this place is [__] booming
and uh half of them are from New York
people that move here
Brian says dragged across concrete
should be available this week on Netflix
oh that's good because I've been wanting
to see that like and we hadn't got
around to it yet so maybe we can if it's
if they show it like we'll uh who said
that Brian did okay
okay so yeah so she kind of feels like
somebody's watching her but you know Ed
of course is just kind of like oh you
know maybe it's nothing or maybe there
is somebody back there I don't know he's
like anyway I'll put in some new locks
and blinds and [__] like that and
everything will be fine
now a few nights later like now this
went this is kind of one of those
paranormal cases that went from like
zero to sixty like in one second it
wasn't just a thing where it's like oh
we thought we heard like weird little
noises and stuff and that then it like
builds up it was basically went from I
felt like someone was watching me to
like full-on Apparition you know what I
mean it's like a few nights after they
move in
Ed is sleeping and he gets woken up he's
smelling smoke and you know as you would
he thinks the house is on fire so he
basically basically like yells at Beth
go get the baby you know I think there's
a fire I smell a fire and then he goes
down looking for where like what's
burning and he looks in one of the
bedrooms
and he said I saw a guy
sitting on the bed like smoking a cigar
yeah he gave me more details yeah
in the in the uh episode he's blue
that's not what he said he wasn't he he
said he didn't look blue or anything he
didn't he looked like a just a regular
living dude and he was sopping wet like
he had been rained on yeah they didn't
share that in the episode did they she
was sopping wet like he was rained on
and uh he was uh Dressed kind of like a
lumberjack he was he had a flannel shirt
on
and a final work shirt and uh work pants
and work boots like he'd been outside
digging that's what he'd look like oh
he'd been digging and we walked in and
saw him and he was
mid drag pull it on a big old [__]
cigar and he said he could see his eyes
looking over the top of that the red hot
so that [__] cigars he was taking a
drag and he said the eyes were just
[__] scary so the the eyes were just
real stunning uh
and it it shocked him and he
turned away to call his wife or
something
or or
he said you get out of here that was
that was that was one of the things he
said too and then the dude was gone he
vanished he'd somehow vanished in
between I don't remember the exact order
of the things that he'd said
but he basically started barking at him
you know get the get out of my house
but he wasn't there anymore
now did he immediately I don't know if
he addressed this but did he immediately
know that it wasn't a person no did he
think it was that was a dude I thought
it was a dude yes where'd he go you know
he was looking for him you know yeah
because you wouldn't immediately jump to
ghost unless he was like see-through he
was just sitting there taking a drag off
that cigar it was
the cherry on it was lighting up he
could see his eyes and his eyes were
stared across him he said it was just uh
real [__] spooky
like I can imagine yeah like he had just
done something bad so that's what he I
think if I remember from her correctly
that's what he he said that he had done
like he he was out digging and had done
something bad something like that that's
[__] up yeah yeah so he sees it so you
look real guilty yeah
and so that's what he had smelled was
the cigar smoke
now by the time Beth gets there with the
baby she's like so where's the fire and
he's like dude there was a there was a
guy there was like a guy sitting right
there and she was like there's not a guy
there now though but and she was just it
was not even funny because they kind of
they interviewed the real lady you know
what I mean and she was just kind of
like not having it even though she saw
apparitions too like later on but she
was on the show being like well you know
there's no fire so I'm going back to bed
and like trying to [__] this [__] yeah
and I don't remember if his wife could
smell the cigar or not or if it was just
it
yeah she didn't I mean on the show they
didn't really show her
I mean she was just reacting to him
saying like I Smell Smoke you know get
the baby out of here yeah that doesn't
that doesn't mean that it's false it
could be that
Ed was selected to see that Apparition
by whatever force does it and it may
have not actually been there it might
have just been a mental imprint into his
mind it like a message
you know an image that he picked up
military and police guys have weird
have a tendency to [__] see
paranormal [__]
I think it has to do with just being
more primal you know it's something that
animals can do it was a message from the
past I think
you know it's
that that some something bad had
happened to somebody in that area he
picked up on it
a memory from the past kind of deal like
a 3D hologram in your mind
yeah maybe so they didn't they did go a
little bit into what maybe the history
of the house was but not it's not like
super into he just saw a man that's not
a [__] outlandish claim right it was
just a man and a man looked like he had
done something bad yeah that's basically
what it was and like you said even
though on the show they showed him
looking like ghostly like or or they had
him like painted blue or painted green
or something like that so he'd look like
otherworldly yeah but you said that Ed
Dunham said he just looked like yeah
because I asked like a living guy I said
what do you look like in them and he
said did he look like they showed him in
the episode he said no he's like a
regular guy I thought it was a guy in
the house right but he was [__] scary
yeah you know [__] head's a big dude
man he's [__] big about six feet
probably meaty okay yeah and you know X
Ranger
bad boy 75th infantry you know what I
mean
there has to be some kind of under
underlying [__]
spiritual tone to a [__] to
scare a dude like that you know I mean
he's and he vanished which of course
you're gonna [__] flip the [__] out
are you going crazy did you just see
right you know what I mean was that a
ghost or did you just hallucinate
but he knew he saw it
he said he could smell that cigar smoke
yeah well he said like it woke him up
yeah that's what because he thought the
house was on fire yeah well there
there's been other
um accounts of people having
premonitions and visions and they can
feel or sense the vision coming and that
might have been another manifestation of
it he smells the smoke and then he goes
out and tries to see where it's coming
from and it builds up it builds up and
then he gets the message he sees it
you hit him yeah
so shortly after this
um Beth discovers that she is pregnant
again
so like I said they have the baby Emily
who looked like she was maybe about one
or maybe like 18 months or something
like that it was kind of hard to tell
so they're kind of worried that they're
not going to be able to afford another
kid uh but they're still like pretty
excited and happy about it even though
it was uh not planned you know what I
mean but they were just kind of like ah
we'll we'll figure it out we'll see
we'll make it work
so uh so Beth actually starts taking a
lot of naps in the afternoon because you
know you get pregnant you get kind of
tired and worn out
um so while Emily is down for naps like
she takes a nap so one afternoon though
she wakes up in the bedroom and she also
sees an apparition but this time it's
like an old lady like in a I guess she
was like wearing a nightgown with like a
night dress type of situation she said
she was like standing in the bedroom
door and like she was just standing
there looking at her
and
again it did kind of seem like she just
thought it was a person like she didn't
think it was a ghost immediately even
though on the show they made it look
like spooky like a ghost but she thought
it was a person
so she calls Ed at work and she's like
there's somebody in the [__] house so
Ed like rushes home but of course he
doesn't see anybody so Beth is like it
was this old lady and she like describes
what the woman looked like
and Ed is kind of bemused and he said oh
that sounds kind of like my mom because
I guess like his mom had died of cancer
like at some point like earlier
and so he's kind of like oh neat you
know like maybe maybe my mom is like
watching over us or something like that
and Beth is just like not having it
she's like if it was your mom like why
the hell is she scaring the [__] out of
your pregnant wife that's not cool so
she's like I don't think it's your mom
but you know so there was that whole
situation
so uh so Beth doesn't really like being
in the house anymore so it seems like
it's kind of like especially after
seeing the old lady she's really very
unsettled so she kind of just takes the
baby out for a walk all the time because
you know she doesn't like being in the
house by herself because you know uh
Ed's at work all day
so she has taken the baby out for a walk
and then she comes back into the house
and she goes into the fridge like to get
the baby like a drink or something and
then she looks up and sees all the
cabinet doors in the kitchen are all
open yeah that's Poltergeist right there
yeah
and she's like what the [__] and then
she hears the shower running down the
hall
and I guess it was in the bathroom
that's like attached to their bedroom so
at first I mean she's weirded out
because of the cabinets and the first
she thinks well maybe Ed came home early
and he's in the shower but she goes in
there the bed the bedroom door is closed
but the bathroom door is open and she
goes and calls to Ed like she goes in
the bathroom and the curtains closed and
she can hear the water running
and she calls him and nobody answers and
then she whips the thing aside and
there's nobody in there like but the
water stops like before she opens it but
it seemed like it was still on because
it seemed like it like um
like it seemed like it had been on yeah
because it was like dripping but I don't
know if that's real what really happened
or she was just hearing it like I don't
know if it had really been on or not
because she didn't see it on
so yeah so then she's like well [__] and
then she realizes that she left Emily
like in her stroller in the kitchen like
all by herself because you know she
heard the shower and went off down the
hall and so she goes back into the
kitchen and all the cabinet doors are
open again so she's like all right [__]
this [__] I'm just gonna go out and sit
out in the yard
so her and the baby like you know when
Ed comes home from work uh he finds Beth
and Emily like waiting outside like just
sitting outside in the yard
and uh she's like yeah I'm not uh
hanging out in that house like by myself
because all kind of freaky [__] is
happening in there today and I am not
having it
um so then at this point Ed starts his
campaign of like yelling at the house
and the apparitions they're in this is
your house you know this is your house
you have the right to live in it yeah
and she's like well I was like tell that
to the [__] ghost then it's like
they're the ones being weird in there
but yeah he basically like yells at the
house he's like you know why don't you
mess with me instead of my pregnant wife
and all this other kind of stuff
so that night they said that um that
Beth and Ed like argued a lot about what
they were gonna do about the ghosts and
Ed is basically like I'll find a way to
fix it I'll find out where it's because
you know he's that kind of guy and uh
also he tells Beth to lighten up and I
was like that's probably not a good
thing to say to her like after what
happened but you know and while they're
both in there like in the kitchen kind
of arguing about what they're gonna do
about it they both hear like a knocking
sound like on the walls like in the
kitchen
they did both say they heard that right
they were both like standing there yeah
and it was moving around yeah like well
and it for a second it seemed like Ed
was almost like making light of it
because he went over there that he's
like I'm Gonna Knock back like that and
then like it did it again and she's like
um please stop that you know what I mean
you're just making it worse yeah this is
Poltergeist type activity yeah they're
known for that which you know is this
haunting or Poltergeist or is it
Poltergeist that can make
uh uh apparitions you know yeah I don't
know I don't know I don't know it wasn't
there
neither was that could be either
usually ghosts don't move anything
yeah
so a few days after that
um Ed's son Matt who's 12. he comes for
the weekend like he usually comes and
stays with him every weekend I guess the
rest of the time he lives with his mom
so he's in the I guess he's sleeping on
the couch like in the back some room
type thing
and he's watching TV and I guess the way
they portrayed it on the show like he
heard breathing or he heard somebody
like calling his name like Whispering
his name like a man's voice or something
like that
and Matt said that he could kind of feel
the tension in the house because you
know Beth and Ed were fighting a lot
because if they didn't know what they
were gonna do about the ghosts and there
was like a lot of you know stress in the
house obviously
um now Ed actually doesn't want to
because Matt was like hey I heard I
thought I heard somebody calling me and
it was like really weird and he was
creeped out but Ed was like no you
didn't hear anything or you didn't see
anything like he was trying to like make
him deny it and Beth is like yeah but
you know she was trying to ask the kid
like what he saw or what he heard but Ed
doesn't want to like involve the kids
but Beth is like well you know maybe we
should get rid of the ghost like before
we let Matt come over here if you don't
want the kid because he's obviously
heard something you know what I mean so
they were kind of like fighting about
that too
but then later that night like Matt is
watching TV and he hears something
outside it seemed like and then he
apparently he saw the same ghost guy
that his dad saw earlier like the cigar
guy that was sitting on the bed
um at least that's what they showed on
the show because they kind of showed him
sitting on the couch and then there was
like a shadow of the of a man and then
they showed him like kind of looking
over like that like oh [__] and then
like the guy like walked through the
thing so I'm guessing that he saw the
same Apparition they did have the kid
well he's not a kid anymore he was
growing up but they had the adult kid on
there talking and he said he was
petrified by that so I'm assuming that
he saw the same
uh the same ghost but he didn't tell
anybody at the time like what he saw he
just like kept it to himself
so then a few days after that Ed and
Beth are both woken up by hearing
something they said it sounded like
something being dragged across the floor
like in the other part of the house
so Ed goes around to look he's like it
really sounded like somebody was in the
house but obviously doesn't see anybody
and starts yelling at the ghosts again
like just get out leave us alone blah
blah and Beth tells him like knock it
off and at this point Ed again he's just
like a complete loss he has no idea what
to do you know as we've mentioned before
a lot of a lot of the dudes like this
are kind of that are kind of this
personality type they get really
um bent out of shape by paranormal stuff
because like I said the most of the
problems that they have in life they can
just punch it or they can like fix it or
like figure it out and this and you
can't do that with this and so they're
just like I'm out of ideas you know what
I mean it's too elusive right and they
don't really like that kind of you know
the guys like that like they seem to
like just you know things that are a
little solid and they can easily figure
out how to fix it you know what I mean
and you can't fix that so he doesn't
know what to do
so he starts doing a bunch of research
and he finds the Daytona Beach
paranormal research group I think is
what they're called I don't know if
they're still around anymore probably
not probably not that was in the web
group this is like a long time ago yeah
Oracle says punching ghosts doesn't help
it it does not it does not
or kicking them or shooting them or
anything
so he basically just posts a request on
there for help so dusty Smith who's the
founder who you said you would kind of
talk to briefly online a while back long
time ago yeah yeah 2010 maybe yeah
she kind of reaches out uh to him so
they talk on the phone for a while and
he kind of tells her what's going on
and Dusty says you know she'll bring her
team to you know to come out and
investigate and see what's going on so
two nights later they show up and they
set up all the equipment and [__] like
that and start interviewing Ed and Beth
while they're all taking like vase
readings around the house and whatnot
now while they're doing the interviews
apparently the whole entire team heard
this banging on the walls like they like
Adam Beth had heard before in the
kitchen
so they were like okay well that's
um pretty definitive there and then I
think they also said that the
temperature like noticeably dropped or
there were like wild temperature
fluctuations like they were going around
and so there was all this banging and
the first thing they thought of was like
oh well maybe it's the water heater so
they go in the garage but Ed comes in
and he's like uh it's not the water
heater I've already checked out like a
hundred times because I thought the same
thing as you but that's not what it was
and they didn't get like an unusual
reading around it anyway
but yeah so they heard like weird noises
in the sound so they go around and start
checking out the spots in the house
where people had seen apparitions you
know what I mean now Dusty said that
when she was standing it seemed like she
was standing in the hallway and like the
ghost or whatever like yanked her head
backward like it looked like he kind of
like grabbed her hair and like yanked
her head back something like that
and Dusty also tells Ed not to yell at
the ghosts uh because he's making it
worse but you know
she was like I know you want to but you
know don't do that because they kind of
feed off negative energy and whatnot
so they set up all the EVP recorders and
you know all the temperature fluctuation
stuff and everything
and so they're there for a while I guess
it seemed like they were just just there
like overnight or whatever and they like
um so they had all the data and stuff
and then they're like okay we're gonna
go back to the you know back to the
office or whatever and we're gonna
analyze all the data and then we'll get
back to you and see what we're gonna do
so the next day Dusty goes to the County
Records Office and gets the property
records for this house
and she discovers that this house has
been sold multiple times
um you know just in the past few years
always for much less than its market
value but you know which might lead some
people to believe that people were just
like leaving or like abandoning it or
selling it quick or whatever
um also kind of a thing about you know
Native American sacred land yada yada
that I feel like that's par for the
course for all of these shows
um and plus I'm not sure they were kind
of a little bit vague on this but she
said she discovered that maybe a man and
an old woman had died in the house like
at separate times you know what I mean
which would account for both of the
apparitions but she didn't really say
how she determined that right because
she heard Ed describe it a man and a
woman yeah so that's what I mean so I
don't really know because they did keep
it kind of big it's not like they were
like hey this guy named you know Mr
whatever like I did live here and he
died in this house like that was
documented I'm not really sure you know
what I'm saying it's it's always kind of
like that they're always like really big
but she said that she thought maybe like
the man of the old woman had died in the
house not at the same time obviously but
like over the years
so she also listens to the EBP stuff
that they recorded
and apparently Dusty is very alarmed
because she can hear more than a dozen
different like distinct voices
so I guess she feels like maybe she's a
little bit out of her depth so she
contacts this this medium that I guess
she knew from before but she lives in
Pennsylvania and her name is Kelly
Weaver and Kelly Weaver is one of those
ones that like what is that called where
they can touch something and they get
like Impressions from like um yeah it's
something like that I can never I can
never remember the words yeah but uh but
yeah she's one of those I guess so she
basically says um you know send me a
photo of the house but don't tell me
anything else about it and I'll do a
reading on the photo and see what I can
get you know what I mean
so when Kelly gets the pictures in the
mail she touches them and gets a real
real bad headache which she said doesn't
usually happen and she was just kind of
like she said she really dreaded doing
the reading because she knew that there
was something like really [__] up and
bad about this house and she just didn't
want to do it
so a few weeks two weeks later Ed gets
home from work again and finds Beth and
Emily on the lawn again uh Beth is just
like look I'm sick of this [__] house
it's like it's [__] creepy in there
all the time and she's like and I want
to move
um you know she's like I'm gonna have a
baby I don't want to have a baby in this
[__] house because it's like too
stressful
so then they have another big argument
because that's like look we can't afford
it
um you know but she's like we were just
fighting all the time now because like
Not only was she pregnant and then they
also had like a little kid to look after
but then there was all this haunting
[__] going on and all this money
problems and [__] like that so it's just
like they were just basically fighting
about everything and they said that
Emily the kid the baby was also really
cranky and that she wasn't sleeping and
so they thought maybe something was
going on with that that had to do with
the ghost stuff
um Ed was just she's like he was just on
a hair trigger all the time like he was
just constantly annoyed and he was just
getting really nasty and irritable and
everything like and she said everything
was setting him off and Beth was just
like I just wanted to be left alone and
I was like that's poor woman but yeah
she was like she had a lot she had a lot
to put up with I'm just saying
so then
um Ed basically calls Dusty up and says
look you know we can't take it anymore
uh we eat these ghosts out ASAP yeah he
goes full Karen on the [__] [__]
because he wanted and he even said this
and Dusty said something about this too
but and I think she's like I think a lot
of people they think they're gonna call
the paranormal group and the paranormal
group is going to come in there and be
like you know and kick the ghosts out
and everything's gonna be over and she's
like and that's not usually how it works
out so the fact that like Ed would be
like calling her up and like yelling at
her like yo come here and get these
ghosts out of here like right now and
she's like you know I can't really do
that because kind of like do what they
want you know what I'm saying but he was
kind of getting upset about it
so um so apparently she's gonna come out
to the house because he called her at
the office and so he's on the she's on
the way out there and in the meantime he
evidently sees
the sees something like sees an
apparition on the roof like he goes
outside and like sees a dark figure I
thought they heard something walking on
the ceiling something like that I don't
think they showed that on the ship on
the show but you said that he told you
that he said from what I remember he
said he'd hear things walking across the
the rafters in the in the um attic there
wasn't much of an attic there and then
sometimes you hear things walking across
the roof
and he was getting sick of it he never
could catch it yeah that's what I
remember it was a long time ago that I
talked to him about it though
I mean I remember you saw it on the roof
yeah because they showed that they
showed that yeah he couldn't quite make
out what it was it was just a black
cloud
on a on a black background at night on
the on just running around on the rear
seat because he had like a flashlight or
something but yeah you see just
I don't know if he had a flashlight in
real life but on the show on the show he
did he didn't mention anything about
that from what I remember he said he
couldn't quite see it he just saw
something moving across and he said hey
you you get off there you know yelling
at it I see you I see you yeah that kind
of [__] yeah he was just he was getting
a little yeah a little a little antsy
yeah a little crabby
um but yeah so while he's out there
yelling at the ghost on the roof yeah
that goes on the roof uh Dusty pulls up
in the car and again tell us please
don't do that like don't yell at the
ghost because uh you know you're just
making everything a million times worse
because that's they feed on negative
energy and they probably get a kick out
of
um you know out of antagonizing you
and uh apparently I don't know if Dusty
took a picture of whatever was on the
roof or if Ed did but they said the
picture just had it didn't show like a
figure but it just had a bunch of orbs
which you know are usually [__]
usually [__] dust yeah dust or bugs
or something like that so I don't I've
never seen it or biology yeah I'm not
into that orb thing either that's it
because there's too many other things
that could be it's not it's not
impressive like I said if you want to
impress me with a ghost picture like
take a picture and then it has like a
big [__] demon face or something like
that and you didn't Photoshop that [__]
then I'll be impressed but not orbs I'm
like yeah it's a moth okay just calm
down
so um
Dusty also says that um Ed is probably
like uh rylingly goes up because they
know because they know that he can see
them yeah you know what I mean so they
get a kick out of like trying to get a
rise out of him
so so dusty comes in the house and
there's like okay well what the [__] are
we gonna do and she's like well we could
call a priest and they're like well you
know they didn't seem like they were
real religious and they don't belong to
a church and it's like I don't think
we'd be able to get a priest out here
because we're not you know a member of
any church or anything like that and
um you know Ed is starting to get kind
of aggressive because he's feeling like
you know there's nothing that can be
done about this and Dusty's like well we
could try to do a cleansing ourselves
like in a couple of days
so also
um at this point Beth says I think
something might be going on in Emily's
room like in the nursery because she
hasn't been sleeping like she's always
waking up and crying and she's always
like really cranky and it seems like
she's not sleeping at all so maybe
there's something going on in there too
so dusty says okay well I'm gonna set up
like a recorders
in Emily's room so we can see if
something's happening in there as well
and while they're doing that it seems
like
um because Emily has already been put
down to sleep for the night and the baby
starts crying and then the bedroom door
like starts rattling and then Ed starts
like freaking the [__] out like just
running around the house yelling at the
[__] because he's just yelling at the
ghost through this whole thing you think
you're in hell now you think I'm just
like what are you gonna do exactly what
are you gonna do exactly play
psychological [__] work
now that I'm here in this case again
after so much time this is Poltergeist
this isn't ghost
it's just consistent with Poltergeist
I'll get into it I'll get into it later
though after after you tell yeah I'm
almost done with the with the with the
recap yeah so then you can get into it
yeah
so um so basically because that happened
they're like okay well we're moving the
baby's crib into
edin Beth's bedroom because they were
like afraid to leave her by herself
because you know the rattling and
whatnot
um at this point Dusty was like I really
liked the Dunhams and um it really
bummed me out like to watch their family
disintegrating because they were just
like losing it like Ed was losing it and
it's like you could tell that the baby
wasn't sleeping and like Beth was like
super stressed out and they just weren't
dealing well with the whole situation
and she's like and it really kind of
broke my heart to see because they've
seen like nice people
so a couple nights later Dusty and the
team come back to do the cleansing and
they do the sage and the holy water and
yada yada like all the stuff and they
even make uh well they didn't make her
like Beth actually wanted to do it but
she was going around with the sage like
only positive energies and the blah blah
you know what I mean
um and then Dusty gives them like a
Saint Michael prayer card and all that
now Dusty goes to switch out the
videotape in
Emily's room and they said everything
was pretty calm after the cleansing but
then the next day Dusty watches the tape
that they recorded in Emily's room like
in the nursery
and we don't know what was on the actual
tape what they showed on the show was
that there was like a voice
she did say that there was a voice
calling Emily's name and she said it
didn't sound like a man or a woman like
it sounded like a weird just voice like
calling the baby's name
and that on the show they kind of showed
like the door to the nursery like
opening by itself and then there was
like a shadow like across the thing
maybe like a shadow like kind of leaning
over the crib you know like while the
baby was in there
so that's apparently I don't know if
that's really what was on the tape but
that's what they showed on the show
um also in Pennsylvania the medium Kelly
who had the pictures uh she was doing
the reading at around the same time and
she said she was touching the photos and
they photos were like pulsating in her
hand and so much negative energy she
thought it was going to explode blah
blah so you know what I mean she never
came down there to go to the place or
anything like that so that didn't like
factor into it at all
so yeah so I don't know
so so dusty sees what's on this tape and
wigs out she's like okay whatever it is
it's in this house like the kid is in
danger for sure so she tries to call the
family but the phone is [__] up just
like in the Amityville Horror you know
what I mean like when she tries to call
the priest and like the phone keeps
going like you can so yeah it was like
that so she tries to call but the
phone's [__] she's like okay well I'm
gonna go over there right now and she's
like and then while she's going over
there like Kelly calls her and says holy
[__] I was just doing the photo reading
on the house and it's like there's they
need to get out of there there's all
kind of like bad [__] and like negative
Mojo about that house and she's like I'm
on my way over there right now I just
saw like some horrible [__] on the
videotape so we gotta get them out of
there
so dusty races over the house and says
basically
um you know your baby is in danger uh
you know what's on this tape is [__]
horrifying I don't know if he should if
they she showed it to him or not and
it's like you just need to get the [__]
out of this house like right now so um
they were like Okay can do uh and
basically they just like packed their
[__] and left
um kind of like the way they found it
people just leave it that's well yeah
and I think that's kind of weird it came
full circle you know what I mean I think
they should like while they were packing
up didn't like the bed kind of go like
move by itself you know what I mean and
they're just like yep okay we're going
right you know what I mean
um and they end up going to Beth's mom's
house
thank you David June popping in to send
some love thank you very much uh your
shirts should be arriving I think I told
you this already but you sure should be
arriving on Wednesday because they
picked them up this morning yeah they
came out good and it was a priority mail
so it should be there in a day or two
so thank you very much for that there's
any problem getting contact with me yeah
yeah
um yeah so they basically like run out
the house and they go to I think they
went to Beth's mom's house and like
stayed there for a little while yeah um
and Ed he says they barely escaped so I
guess all kind of horrible [__] was
going on so they so they moved to
another town they didn't say where they
moved to but they said it was like
another nearby town so I don't know if
they moved to Daytona or so Stanford
maybe it was Stanford because that's
where we saw him working like a few
years later
um and Beth ends up having a baby boy
and Emily they were worried about Emily
that she might have like seen some bad
[__] and like she'd be traumatized or
whatever but I guess she was like too
young when it happened because like she
didn't she grew up a little bit and she
didn't remember anything so they were
like happy about that
so then at the end like the interview Ed
a little bit and he says that he finally
after all this time after all the
yelling at the ghost that he did he
finally understands that he couldn't
fight this thing and I wrote down the
quote that he said he said I don't care
how big or tough or mean you think you
are you're not gonna win yeah that's
what he said it's not physical and I was
like well that was a good Insight that
you have there you can get physical with
you you can't get physical with it
um
Dusty and their team they came out with
the ghost hypothesis but if you look at
this case
in total
that's Poltergeist
think about it
you got kids in the house of the right
age a pregnant woman
you got a high strung Army Ranger
they're under stress they got money
problems
um tension in the household
that's already
the very basic template for Poltergeist
to happen
then the phenomenon itself
knocking
dragging sounds
footsteps up now near the roof and up
near the ceilings
um cabinets cabinets open shower running
shower running things open and closing
um what else do they see that actually
moved uh the bed moved
um
that was pretty much it pretty much it
right that's very common Poltergeist
phenomenon now
apparitions are not that common in
Poltergeist neither are voices
but the ones that I saw eventually tried
to speak I ran from it when it tried to
speak or you didn't want to hear what it
had to say was trying to form words yeah
I don't think I'd want to hear anything
yeah I didn't want to hear nothing about
that jumped up and ran all right um nope
yeah nope the [__]
sleeping bag and everything
[Laughter]
I don't blame you now a little bit I
want to hear that what that thing is
going to try to say
and um
we didn't see any apparitions in terms
of humanoid apparitions but we saw like
little spherical Distortion type things
you weren't quite sure were there and
blue haze like this blue haze that you
weren't you could see it everybody could
agree when it was there but you really
couldn't
you really weren't sure yeah you're like
is that there yeah it's there you know
what I mean but
it wasn't solid it was some kind of
energy field or something
so this is a Poltergeist
even even let's say even if they saw
something on the video what they're
saying is they saw a shadow and a door
opening and a voice that's consistent
with Poltergeist too
I mean maybe that's what was on the
video that's what they showed in the
arena right I don't know I've seen how
impressive the phenomenon was I'd like
to see it you know
probably not impressive for she was
showed him that's that's my hunch maybe
nothing
but the rest of the phenomenons
consisted with Poltergeist
and Poltergeist isn't artificially
generated ghost
by the subconscious mind to somebody in
that house
and the family has to have the right
Synergy has to be a Synergy of
breakup tension and the the Poltergeist
projected
into the world moving objects
it's kind of like a
artificial threat to the family to get
them to kind of bind together tighter in
the face of a common threat
that's what its function is at a
psychological level
that's Poltergeist man it's not ghost
although it didn't really work that way
in this case because it seemed like they
just started fracturing more than
anything yeah but which I guess that
happens too but they did all leave
together that's true so maybe that
worked
and then even if you did like a little
Seance or a blessing or some [__] like
that
that might
kind of pacify whoever's making the the
Poltergeist if they believed it worked
maybe it would work but I in general
things like that don't work
exorcisms don't work
uh because it's not a demon so you can't
cast it back out to Hell a kid's making
it in the original story that the that
the Exorcist was based on
one of the guys helping I think he was
like an altar boy that was helping it
when he saw the phenomenon he recognized
it immediately as Poltergeist not not a
demon but a poltergeist
and evidently the church thought it was
a poltergeist
even in the movie they said this isn't a
real demon
yeah the holy water burned it that's not
that's not holy water that's just
regular tap water well that's one of the
tricks they always do yeah well even I
think even the church as much as I [__]
on them for like you know believing in
demons in the first place but they do
have a very strict set of protocols
because they usually do that holy water
stick like we're gonna say it's holy
water except not really
um and one of the rules too is like the
don't they have to like be able to speak
languages that they don't know how to
speak or something like that like they
have a bunch of like rules that it has
to be yeah if it's a demon it would
speak kind of languages that the kid
doesn't know right
yeah like if it like if the kid was
speaking like Aramaic or something like
that I think it's Latin they want the
kid to speak that there would be no way
that the kid would know how to speak
then yeah that would obviously suggest
something but you know I'm just well
this this is interesting to me because
it started out
if it is Poltergeist and if it did
happen the way that it was shown on the
show it didn't really follow the classic
pattern usually you would get stuff like
you know cabinet doors opening shower
running knocking stuff like that like
early on first thing they felt and then
later
first thing they said was the feeling of
being watched well she did yeah and then
like but then a couple days later like
he immediately saw an apparition and
then a couple of days after that she saw
an apparition yeah and then they started
hearing yeah it was out of order but
yeah it's not impossible that it could
be out yeah yeah I'm just saying I just
thought it was interesting because it's
not he didn't follow you usually usually
Poltergeist starts small and it works
his way up like scratching noises or
something or something right whoever's
generating it has to
um Master certain basic skills first and
get get the subconscious has to get the
the the confidence to do it you know
and um it has to discover new tricks
although the one that I saw I think it
was running out of tricks
the last unique thing that he tried to
do
was to talk
yeah and they only tried it once
and it didn't say anything it just made
a weird noise it's just garbled yeah
sounded like it was underwater and
talking backwards that is thin air
couldn't make out what it was saying
it started off as
like bubbles going through water
sounded like backward masking on the
damn record it's because my hair [__]
stood up like that
well yeah that's that's a sound you
really don't want to hear coming out of
thin air came out of thin air
[Laughter]
about five feet off the ground and about
three feet out from a corner in a room
and it was dark so you know because that
[__] sounds freaky even if you know what
it is even if it's like a record playing
backward it's still creepy sounding and
if it was just coming out of thin air
yeah I got up off that cot and [__]
jumped out of the [__] sleeping bag
and [__] grab the sleeping bag with
me
[Music]
left Wesley's sleeping ass in there with
it and the night before it had thrown
all the damn laundry on me from the from
the dressers from the dresser uh
Poltergeist yeah throwing [__] on me
they're throwing clothes on me yeah
clean clothes
Ben says Ben made a good point actually
uh people children subconsciously caused
the phenomenon but it is referenced by
their cultural expectations so if
they've seen movies like Poltergeist and
the phenomena will be similar yeah yeah
and I do kind of feel like and we we've
kind of talked about this before that if
for example the family is religious then
a lot of times a poltergeist you know
outbreak will mirror religious we'll
mimic like a religious Motif like that
and the more you expect it to act a
certain way the more it acts like that
yeah like so if you expect it to be a
ghost or a haunting it'll start acting
like that or yeah I remember hearing
some weird ass cases reading them back
in the 80s stuff that happened in the
60s or the 70s supposedly
and um
where some little boys Poltergeist was
acting kind of demonic but then once the
kid got into a good mood it would do
things like just from out of nowhere
just drop [__] hundreds of [__]
rose petals just out of this out of the
sky you know what I mean you just you
never they never saw where they came
from it's just people would be in the
room they'd see that they were already
falling
little rose petals nobody knows where
they came from that's pretty weird yeah
can we bring little gifts and stuff try
to make amends better than that throwing
rocks at you like it usually does
dropping rose petals
because a lot of them like Drop rocks on
your [__] house like jerks
David June said uh got Mammoth Mountain
Poltergeist on Audible last year really
scary story I find myself listening to
it every few months yeah
yeah I still remember when you first
told me that story I think you didn't
want to tell me at first because you
thought I wasn't gonna believe you
got Lois and red on the phone now I'm
[__] there tell them to sing I didn't
believe you at first but I was like man
that is a crazy [__] story yeah
and uh yeah [__] so weird man I grew
up with that [__]
always looking over my shoulder
and then having [__] out of body
experiences near-death experiences and
[__]
and then
but think about it too much it comes
back you know last time it hasn't it's
done a few things here but it's just
phenomenal you know I haven't figured
anything here through the ring but you
have yeah yeah through that little skull
ring
um
I think that was all it's done
yeah I remember you telling me about
that but I wasn't home yeah or I was in
the other room or something I looked at
that ring as my eyes were scanning
across my my eyes landed on it for a
second when I looked away it I saw the
corner of my eye it flip up and then
fluttered down and float down the ground
like a [__] leaf
and it's metal
then it happened so fast
it'll happen Jenny seen me do it it'll
happen and I don't notice it until after
it's gone like when it threw the remote
you know I was just you're kind of in a
weird mental state where you're ignoring
it you're focused on something else
thank you very much Dom the bomb hi
Jenny and Tom sorry not been around as
much of late but have a drink on me
thank you very much very much that's
awesome I was yeah I was thinking the
other day that it's like it did a bunch
of [__] at our house at Sanford and I
think we usually forget to bring this up
but remember how it opened the that
patio door yeah that we never opened
yeah I found even though the lock was
still it was still locked it had a dead
ball the deadbolt was still still out
but the it was a two-part it was wide
open yeah it was wide open and Beijing
is sitting there just looking at it like
that's not right and we never opened
that yeah never opened that door I think
we opened it one time like when we were
moving in like to move something out
onto like the grill or something out
onto the porch but other than that we
never opened it and I got up to go to
work and it was like the one of it was
open and the deadbolt was still engaged
and Beijing was just like sitting there
looking out the door going what the [__]
she was like looking at it like that
yeah why is that open and I'm sitting
there going
um I don't know sweetie I don't know why
it's like that and I don't think it had
been been open for very long probably
not
thank you again David June
Dom gives a drink I offer a shooter
man we're gonna be [__] up by the time
by the time this is uh over
but yeah because I'm I got my lemonade
lemonade and vodka anything else you
would like to add to the Ed Dunham
Haunting in Florida case no I think
that's I think that's enough
that's it I think it pretty much think
that's enough yeah I think it was
Poltergeist
Yeah the more you talk about it like I
said it did kind of seem like oh so many
apparitions but I don't know it was they
did Poltergeist they didn't have the
same yeah and like I said I had a whole
chapter in my unseen Handbook of the
ones that apparitions were involved
there was usually other [__] going on
too but like some people did kind of see
apparitions at some point if this would
have been a weak Poltergeist in terms of
physical phenomenon but it's real strong
in apparition
you know that's kind of an unusual
feature
and the apparitions they both of them
apparently said that they just look like
real people yeah like because they saw
different ones like she saw an old lady
and he saw like that guy and I guess the
son saw the guy he may not take any
energy to do that it's just like a mind
trick you know what I mean it puts that
image in your mind and you believe you
saw it
that would yeah well like you said it'd
be easier than like actually making yeah
it probably doesn't make a hologram yeah
it probably doesn't make a hologram it
just makes you have a hallucination that
you saw it puts the image in your mind
so strong that yeah you did see it but
it wasn't there if somebody else saw it
it wouldn't be there you know what I
mean yeah like the wife didn't say she
smelled the cigarette smoke but he did
or the cigar smoke but he smelled it
that's part of the hallucination
yeah
Zach said uh did y'all catch the Oscars
last night no I forgot it was on they
were talking about it at work and
because there's a couple movies that
were nominated or that one that I had
wanted to see but I haven't got around
to it yet I was actually watching last
well last night we watched a haunting we
watched this episode and then I started
watching
on Netflix
um what's it called sins of my mother
that three episode True Crime thing
about that [__] crazy Lori valo and
Chad dabell case I think we talked about
it well I got one more to watch but I'll
watch that like after the show's over
but
um I think we talked we didn't do a
whole show about it I don't think but I
think we did remember when we used to do
like news
segments like at the beginning of the
show and I think we did one about that
because it was very much like in the
news at the time yeah so I wanted to see
because I kind of forgot like how that
resolved itself so I watched two of the
episodes last night so I'm gonna watch
one of them now and so that is a [__]
crazy ass story you can't make that [__]
up yeah but uh yeah so thank you
everybody for dropping by and thanks for
super chats this evening uh we'll be
back on Wednesday and actually Wednesday
should be a really fun show because
um the topic that won
is
televangelist skills all right so we're
gonna be talking about
um I had to pick which ones I wanna so
we'll we'll talk about Jim and Tammy
Faye we'll talk about uh maybe Ted
Haggard maybe Jimmy Swaggart
you know I don't know we'll figure out
what the most interesting ones are but
uh but yeah so that should be a fun show
because that's always kind of fun to
like make fun of
and other that Kenneth Copeland we got
to talk about Kenneth Copeland because
that guy is a [__] that guy is in
that case he's a [__] lunatic I was
watching a video Songify him and [__] uh
well I was watching like a little video
about him on my lunch hour day like on
my phone and I was like oh my God this
dude is like [__] crazy yeah it's
just like the facial expressions he
makes and stuff like oh my God it's like
he's tripping on acid I don't know what
his problem is it's crazy but I mean
it's it's something so yeah we
definitely have to talk about that
[__] too because holy [__] I
can't believe he's for real you know
what I'm saying uh but yeah imagine have
sex with that dude
oh
thanks Tom you just killed my sis my sex
drive forever
why did why did you do that because
that's the that's the least sexy
[__]
imagine you got paid you're the
prostitute you got you're getting paid
you have to be like not for any price
no
I mean I don't think you could pay I
don't think he could pay me enough and
Copeland I don't even think you could
pay me enough to like touch that dude
motherfucker's crazy much less I mean he
looks like Alfred E Newman and [__] I
don't know what the [__] his problem is
he doesn't like I said he looks like
he's like not even a real person I can't
even I can't like Alfred Newman crossed
bread with Yoda because I don't know
it's great or that that [__] that
does ventriloquist dummy from Magic oh
yeah fats fats
all right uh so yeah be sure to tune in
on Wednesday night we're gonna have a
good time making fun of televangelists
and talking about all those [__]
scandals most really from the 80s but we
might talk about like some newer ones
too so uh hopefully you can all uh drop
by for that so thanks for coming by and
hanging out with us this evening and
we'll see you guys on Wednesday good
night